so i wanted to do this one video
to explain the most important
tips and tricks
with doing keto and intermittent fasting
all in one video it's not going to be a
terribly long video but i wanted to
cover the most important things to help
you be more successful
and really experiencing the results that
you're looking for so let's start at the
beginning
you wake up in the morning what do you
do well most people drink a cup of
coffee right so the first goal is to
skip your breakfast
and the best way to do that is to
add some mct oil in your coffee
start with one tablespoon because if you
start with too much you can end up with
diarrhea
so mct oil is
a type of fat
usually from coconut oil that's going to
allow you to
not be hungry for the next several hours
okay so you put that in your coffee you
mix it up if you work up to two
tablespoons you're gonna find that
you're really not gonna be hungry it's
gonna actually give you energy now what
i normally do is after the coffee and
you can do this before the coffee
i like lemon water but i take the whole
lemon and i blend it with water
i don't take the juice of the lemon
anymore now it's going to be very very
tart so you can add
you know several drops of stevia or what
i do is i put my electrolyte powder in
this mixture like one scoop that way you
get the potassium magnesium so you have
more energy so we have this super
powered lemon water with electrolytes or
without it that gives you a lot of
vitamin c but it also gives you
something called citrates
which help
prevent
kidney stones okay so now that you're
not hungry
in the morning you go all the way to
noon and you have your first meal
i recommend doing maybe a tablespoon of
apple cider vinegar in a glass of water
drink that
that will help you digest it's also
going to help your blood sugars but you
don't have to necessarily do it before
the meal you can do it
while you're fasting but apple cider
vinegar is a really good thing to take
when you're doing this for energy for
blood sugars to help speed up the
improvement of the insulin resistance
now as far as the meal goes i always
recommend doing your vegetable or salad
before your protein why because i found
that if you're going to do what i
usually recommend is between seven to
ten cups of vegetables per day which a
lot of people can't do that initially
that means you're gonna have to do a big
salad right i mean a five cup salad is
not that big and maybe you could do five
cup salad and then for dinner do like
three cups or two cups right it's not
hard to do that now if you're doing
other vegetables like broccoli
cabbage
brussels sprouts more dense vegetables
you're not going to be doing seven to
ten cups okay maybe you do four to five
cups so i recommend in doing the
vegetable or salad first because it's
that way it seems to work out a little
bit better so on the salad
one thing that i do that actually tastes
quite good is i sprinkle
nutritional yeast flakes on the salad
it's a way to get my b vitamins uh
through the day and it will definitely
reduce your stress and it actually
tastes a little bit like parmesan cheese
so it's a a great thing to sprinkle on
your salad i would highly recommend
getting the one that's non-fortified
because the fortification they put these
synthetic vitamins in there and i'll put
a link down below if you want more
information on that the two major groups
of nutrients that i recommend as a bare
minimum would be the electrolytes and
the b vitamins
when you're doing keto to prevent the
keto fatigue the keto rash and any other
symptoms because when you first start
this you're going to dump a lot of water
and you're going to lose a lot of
electrolytes and some people get really
tired after they do this and they become
dehydrated so we want to put back in the
electrolytes plus when you're burning
more fat
you do need your b vitamins and a lot of
people are
borderline deficient going into this so
they may have fatigue if they don't add
the b vitamins one of the best sources
of the b vitamins is nutritional yeast
so you have your vegetable your protein
okay
how much protein
well that really depends on you know
your metabolism your age if you're male
or female i usually recommend between
three to six
to seven to eight ounces of actual
protein now if you're younger and you
exercise have a little bit more but if
you do too much protein especially at
dinner that could keep you from sleeping
at night all right so at the end of the
meal
i like to add some additional fat why
because
that way i can fast longer and i'm more
satisfied so i might consume a handful
of pecans i might do a whole avocado i
might do
macadamia nuts i might add more olive
oil to the salad
i might just have some more butter on my
food but that fat will help you to fast
longer now at the end of this meal some
people might feel full but they might
not feel satisfied and there's a couple
reasons for that number one they have
insulin resistance okay and that's going
to take some time to fix that and when
you have insulin resistance you just
don't pull the nutrients that much so
you're always going to feel a little um
unsatisfied so that tends to cause you
to eat more the other reason why you
might not feel satisfied is the food
that you're eating is not nutrient dense
okay when you do grass-fed
beef
oh my gosh it has so many more nutrients
than corn fed beef and you won't know it
until you try it so even though it might
have more of an i don't know earthy
taste to it or
kind of a different taste
it's way more nutrient dense more
omega-3 fatty acids there's even
phytonutrients in there because the
cow has eaten a lot of grass
so we have way more beta-carotene and
way more retinol vitamin a and vitamin e
and more trace minerals i mean if you
think about it a cow that is fed a lot
of corn
[Music]
that is very unnatural
has much more marbled fatty
protein like their their muscles are
more fatty well guess what some of these
cows develop insulin resistance
and that creates a nutritional
deficiency in the cow and then you eat
that meat and you have less nutrition so
ideally to feel more satisfied you have
more nutrient-dense foods so
grass-fed beef seafood is really
nutrient-dense
especially with the trace minerals
shellfish is another good one if you
could do liver that would be good
eggs pasture-raised organic eggs are
very nutrient-dense
wild-caught fish is more nutrient-dense
like salmon versus
a skinless chicken breast or protein
powder or getting your foods from a fast
food restaurant even though you take the
bun off to make it keto friendly
it's low quality but i don't want to
overwhelm you okay so there's really two
phases to this the first phase is just
to do low carb even if it's dirty keto
doesn't matter just start doing low carb
second phase is to increase the quality
of what you're eating okay
and that takes a little bit more
knowledge a little bit more time so
do what you can
something is better than nothing so if
you have to start doing low carb and
regardless of the quality do that so we
have this first meal now we're going to
fast until dinner okay now a couple tips
for fasting you can do different types
of herbal teas
green tea is a really good one turmeric
tea is a really good one to help you
fast longer and to spike autophagy which
gives you all these other cool benefits
of anti-aging and more uh brain health
all right we get to the second meal you
can do another drink with apple cider
vinegar with water uh to help your
digestion
and then do your fat at this time maybe
you want to do a good handful of
sunflower seeds which gives you a little
bit more fat and the b1 now at this time
it might be six o'clock okay
let's say hypothetically you're going to
go to bed at 10 o'clock i wouldn't
recommend if you're older and you
potentially might have bladder problems
waking up at the middle of the night i
would recommend not drinking past
like i don't know seven so that would be
three hours before you go to bed so in
other words drink a lot of water through
the day and definitely
maybe after dinner and maybe right at
seven but not drink a lot of liquid like
seven eight or nine o'clock because
that sleep is going to be very very
important and the less water you drink
the better now this is a really key
thing between the last meal and before
you go to bed a lot of times i know this
might be hard to believe they
want a snack on foods and this is the
killer for
staying in ketosis
some people non-stop snacking between
the time that they eat dinner and the
time they go to bed so the most
important tip is to just do not have
snack foods in your house
get these potential
tempting snacks out of the house if you
absolutely must
eat something
just eat celery it's crunchy and that
way it'll give you something to chew on
but
boy this is a real problem for a lot of
people so if you do what i said eat
nutrient dense foods and more fat at the
end of the meal your chances of snacking
will be less
all right
sleeping is going to be very important
if you don't sleep well you're going to
find that you're going to crave in the
morning because it's going to increase
cortisol you'll be more stressed it's
going to be harder to get the results
that you want it's going to affect your
metabolism so a couple little tips for
sleeping
during the day if you can exercise that
would be awesome because exercise will
deplete your energy it improves your
blood sugars it will help your sleep if
you can exercise outside or be outside
during the day that's also going to be
important because the exposure to the
sun is going to give you a lot of
melatonin melatonin is going to help you
sleep so if possible ideally you want to
get at least one hour at least one hour
of exposure to the sun not necessarily
being in the direct sunlight but just
being outside even if you have a hat on
or close
because the uv light from the sun will
penetrate
your clothing and your hat and that will
start building up your melatonin okay
not to mention getting the vitamin d
vitamin d helps your sleep so during the
winter
if you're not getting enough sun and you
and you want to spike your your sleep
take about 10 000 iu's of vitamin d3
right before sleep okay that's going to
help
your sleep cycles and if you have this
excessive thinking
before bed be one before sleep very very
effective so we want to limit too much
protein at the second meal especially to
help you sleep because if you're sitting
on a tremendous amount of protein that's
undigested
it's going to affect your sleep make
sure you get enough melatonin by getting
sun don't take the melatonin supplement
okay that's gonna create another problem
get your melatonin from the infrared
wave from the sun and then you have the
b1 and then the d3 all right and i
forgot to mention this with exercise
to maintain energy with exercise you
need your electrolytes especially
sodium okay and potassium so make sure
when you do this keto that you start
adding more sea salt to your meals if
you don't you'll be deficient in sodium
and that's going to make weak muscles
you're going to feel like wow i just
don't have the energy to exercise it's
usually low sodium which is very easily
handled by putting more sea salt on your
foods now as far as the potassium that's
another electrolyte that's going to keep
your energy up and you can you're going
to get potassium and magnesium from your
salads and the electrolyte powder and i
even want people to feel the difference
by adding just more sea salt and
potassium to
how much
more effective their exercise is in
endurance strength and the desire to
exercise versus being deficient in those
two boy it's dramatic you just don't
feel like working out you don't have the
energy you're dragging all day now a
couple more important things so if
you've checked out just check back in
because this is going to be really
important
we don't want you to plateau right it's
the little things that make a big
difference for example
one way to knock yourself out of ketosis
is by doing the diet
artificial sweeteners okay they can
really mess you up so that's a really
important point
the other point is there's hidden
sugar in even keto-friendly
bars desserts
snacks yes and even though you might be
below the 50 grams of carbs
maltodextrin dextrin are not classified
as sugars believe it or not i've done a
whole video on that
don't trust it read the ingredients
first
in fact if you can avoid the keto snacks
altogether you're probably going to be
in better shape also the so-called keto
electrolyte powders out there have
maltodextrin hidden in their natural
flavorings yes
so that's another thing that i didn't
even know until probably a year and a
half ago but they use maltodextrin as a
spray agent to dry out
certain
flavorings so i had a hard time finding
a company that didn't add the
maltodextrin to the ingredients both in
the citrate form of the minerals as well
as in the natural flavorings so
maltodextrin is worse than sugar it's
worse than glucose it's like really high
in the glycemic index all right a couple
of things
honey
is sugar okay avoid it read ingredients
with honey and avoid it and there's a
lot of other forms of sugar like date
sugar and coconut water there's a lot of
sugar in that and so realize just a
little bit of that sugar or carb can
knock you out of ketosis for a
considerable amount of time up to 48
hours so if you're wondering why you're
not getting results because every other
day you're having these hidden
sweeteners
that's why you see the goal is to get
you to do this right long enough
for you to feel
what you should feel like
as far as the energy the cognitive
benefits not just the weight loss
but just feeling really good because
that healthy feeling that feeling of
wellness the feeling of
being energetic
is so so important especially as you get
older you'll find out it's very valuable
last few tips the best indicator to know
that this is working is your appetite
okay your appetite goes away not weight
loss because it's get healthy
then lose weight not lose weight to get
healthy
so one of the best indicators of getting
healthy is switching over to burning
your fat that's a very very healthy
state that's going to create a lot of
additional health benefits so the loss
of appetite means that you're doing this
okay so go by that as the most important
thing especially when you start out
don't weigh yourself too frequently
because we don't want to focus on your
weight okay we want to focus on energy
appetite cravings going away and then
your clothes feeling looser and last
little point if this is overwhelming
something is better than nothing
just
do low carb okay or
just do fasting as a starting
entry point because even if you have to
start with dirty keto and and do the
atkins bars to help you which is a
loaded with a bunch of crap but at least
it's
below 50 grams of carbs that would be
better than nothing now the next best
video i think you should watch would be
the one that i did on the 7 to 10 cups
of vegetables check that one out i put
it right here
you